vous êtes là quelle surprise tons chauds
je craignais qu'avec noël vous n'ayez
pas le temps de venir me voir ici aussi
que noël vous avez vu il est beau le
savent pas ce qui manque un peu c'est le
froid il fait toujours beau et chaud
dans l'île aux enfants
c'est agréable mais le soir de noël on
aurait aimé avoir un peu de neige je
suis sûr que certains d'entre vous ont
eu la chance aujourd'hui de faire une
bataille de boules de neige ce n'est ce
pas ah je parle mais j'oublie de
préparer le gloubiboulga épiler gâteau
aussi parce que ce soit nous allons
faire un réveillon avec françois
monsieur d'islam et le facteur excusez
moi je me remets au travail
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour à tous
je suis le père noël à père noël dans
l'île aux enfants
c'est incroyable mais qui est celui là
bonjour les enfants
tiens il ya un autre père noël aïe aïe
aïe serait ce le vrai père noël
j'y comprends plus rien de personnel
bonjour mes enfants talent qu'est ce que
ça veut dire il ya déjà de père noël
la situation se complique ça devient de
plus en plus embarrassant nous sommes
droit maintenant on va il ya quelque
chose d'anormal il faut que j'aille voir
ça messieurs écoutez moi
il ne peut y avoir qu'un seul père noël
alors il faut que ceux qui ne sont pas
des vrais père noël enlèvent leurs
costumes sinon on y reconnaîtra rien
c'est moi j'utilise c'est françois oui
je m'étais déguisé en père noël pour
faire une surprise à nos amis mais je
pensais qu'on serait trop il en reste
encore un qui fout je voulais moi aussi
distraire nos jeunes amis chère julie je
suis navré veut écouter c'est pas grave
monsieur 19 mai alors 7 noeuds vrai père
noël
ce ne serait pas très honnête de le
laisser croire en anges
j'ai eu la même idée que monsieur russe
nord et que françois les grands esprits
se rencontrent
résultat nous avons bien rater notre
coup poursuit c'était quand même très
sympathique
un record mais ce coup ci c'est
peut-être le vrai parole nous allons
avoir l'air ridicule cher je me sens
bien reconnaître cette voie bonjour les
enfants
je suis le père don d amy tu sais que
c'est une très bonne idée d'être
déguisés en casseurs
l'idée est excellente ce à ce qu'il ya
le déroutant à notre époque c'est que
n'importe qui a le droit d'avoir de
bonnes idées mais comment avez vous
reconnu une petite idée comme sors tu
sais on avait dit ça au hasard
peut-être un petit rien dans la démarche
des marques
bon enfin en tout cas je vous ai apporté
une belle surprise à qu'est ce que c'est
quasiment j'adore les surprises quoi
s'agit-il
eh bien germain est venu avec moi
germain mais c'est formidable c'est elle
qui chante la chanson de l'île aux
enfants
oui et et ce soir elle va là chantées en
entier mais encore là venez avec nous
venez chance est venue chanter la
chanson de villote année chanter les
enfants avec anne vous est présenté vous
allez chanter avec alain
[Musique]
non
des gens
[Musique]
aidons
le japon n'est pas trop tard il suffit
[Musique]
ça c'est pour ses rires et ses chansons
bâti bonne
m
au printemps
[Musique]
non
si seulement vous pas à vos envies
vivre dans la terrine tous serrés
j'attends la vie
[Musique]
c'est touchant
ils sont dans le noir
bien au chaud votre journée s'achève
vous pouvez ne va dt parvenir chat tenu
d'en mourir
[Musique]
c'est
et
[Musique]
m
et tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]